let's bring you some more on the big
breaking news from America in the last
few minutes Donald Trump former
president United States has been found
guilty of sexually abusing and defaming
E Gene Carroll awarding her a total of
five million dollars against Trump and
damages in a Civil Trial in New York the
federal jury found the former president
not guilty of rape
but they acknowledged that Trump had
abused her and had defamed her by
calling her a liar this followed an
incident in a Manhattan department store
nearly 30 years ago
well I'm joined that by Randy zelen
who's a lawyer from America
a criminal defense attorney it's a
random your reaction to this Breaking
News about Donald Trump
you can't spend this one I don't care
who you are that's like saying oh great
news great job I was convicted of I was
acquitted of Murder in the first degree
but convicted of murder in the second
degree spinning it any way you want okay
great he didn't rape her he's still
forcibly intentionally willfully
sexually abused her but her put his
hands on her and sexual parts he was
found libel and then the defamation
that's hey
you a lot about saying that this never
happened you said something that wasn't
true five million dollars may not mean
anything to him but reputation wise his
base may stay but everyone else headed
for the hills Donald Trump's issued a
statement on true social his social
media problem I have absolutely no idea
who this woman is is that it is a
disgrace a continuation of the greatest
Witch Hunt of all time a predictable
response some might think uh from the
ex-president who tends to do this kind
of thing uh but what is the what is the
legal Jeopardy for him now facing all
these other uh legal issues that he's
facing does have any influence on that
at all
no I I think this is all baked in and
what will happen to him in terms of the
January 6th investigation in terms of
the Georgia trying to find eleven
thousand votes in terms of the
classified documents whether he was
found not liable here or found libel
that will have no impact on the other
criminal investigations but what I find
and what resonates with me is exactly
what you were talking about previously
you were talking about hypocrisy and
here the hypocrisy is that if this jury
had come back in two hours and found him
not liable then this would have been the
greatest system in the world the
greatest jurors in the world I can do
whatever I want in New York the mere
fact that they came back with equally
stunning speed
and found against him it's a Witch Hunt
it's rigged and and that's the part to
me that at some level intelligent people
in this country have to start really
focusing in on
all right thank you very much thank you
for joining me I appreciate it
thank you